a las orillas del Río sena el plástico
se ha convertido en parte del paisaje
todos los días miles de fragmentos de
plástico son arrastrados a las Riberas
de su caudal dentro de un metro cuadrado
se encuentran cuatro kilos de plástico
20.000 piezas de escombros de los cuales
la mitad son gránulos de plástico
Industrial en la región de normandía
este geólogo Está tratando de seguir la
ruta tomada durante varios años por los
escombros si plasticla estos plásticos
cuando quedan atrapados en la zona de
algas en los depósitos de marea serán
aplastados contra la madera ejerciendo
múltiples presiones así se generan los
microplásticos
la mayoría de los plásticos miden menos
de 5 milímetros muchos de ellos
provienen de desechos más grandes que se
desintegran con los años y terminan en
el río los científicos advierten que no
todas las piezas terminan llegando al
mar y que pueden permanecer atascadas
durante años en una parte del río
formando zonas de acumulación de
sedimentos los de limpieza patrulla en
el río en un intento por frenar esta
plaga también se han instalado redes de
retención en las salidas de
alcantarillado
esta es la última Barrera que se puede
poner para poder capturar los residuos
sin red van al agua luego se rompe se
convierte en microplástico y luego se
acaba no lo verás no podrás atraparlo
una vez que las redes están llenas se
tienden y se analiza Su contenido
encontrando colillas toallitas
limpiadoras y principalmente artículos
de plástico como botellas los
científicos hacen un llamado al público
para que tome medidas reales lo mejor
que haríamos sería reducir el consumo de
plástico y sobre todo dejar de consumir
plástico de un solo uso
según estudios realizados en 2017 y 2020
el cena vierte entre 100 y 200 toneladas
de plástico al mar cada año